hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's sister location press the red
button now to administer a controlled
shock what why do I want Dancy pants to
be mad at me the text only press three
other options press four I don't
recognize you you are new I remember
this scenario I'm literally cornered
right now baby no no no no no no no none
of Zola
Nana Nana then don't worry about me I
just need to worry about me don't mind
the yelling I know what I'm nervous we
are friends for Oh ever okay thank you
for selecting exotic butters
Oh God is baby on the way oh [ __ ] this
is five nights at baby's got my exotic
butters yes oh the sweet taste of me hey
this just a son of a [ __ ] well I did it
place the crown upon my head and then
call me
[Music]
which